- It's quite simple.
Marketers ruin everything.
(Dramatic music)
Things come along in our world,
radio, television, the internet, Facebook.
Things come along and
they're for the people.
Do you guys remember the
first time you found email?
We loved email.
Email in 1996, 7 and 8 wasn't ruined yet.
How many people here signed
up for Groupon, Living Social,
Daily Candy, one of those sites?
Raise your hand.
Remember three, four years ago
how you couldn't wait to get $40
worth of sushi for 20 bucks?
Or an $80 spa treatment for $40,
that was the greatest thing of all time!
And now you don't give a
rat's ass if they send you
a million dollar home for 100 bucks.
You're like delete, spam,
get the fuck out of my inbox!
And then marketers,
much like myself,
see that people's attention is there,
because my friends its
about this thing right here,
and this thing right here.
I don't give a rat's ass about
fucking Facebook, Twitter,
Tumblr, Pintrest, Instagram
or any of that horseshit.
Where did the customers attention go?
And if you're not there,
and if you're not playing
properly within in that,
you're going to lose.
It's attention!
So when people were
listening to the radio,
people that wanted to sell stuff,
marketers,
realized their paying
attention to the radio,
why don't I stop what they're listening to
and because they're baseball fans,
let me sell them this beer,
and tell them we're the best beer ever,
and interrupt that.
And that process my friends
has gone on for ever and ever.
You can go back to the caves right?
There's a cave,
I use it 'cause I don't wanna
get eaten by a dinosaur.
And some dude wants to sell me a new club,
and he's drew some shit
in there to sell me.
So while my attention was here,
staying away from the dinosaurs,
Hi, maybe I need a new club!
That long and that forever,
wherever there are people
paying attention to something,
marketers like myself want to ruin it.
You know it's all gonna happen.
Google glasses will come out,
we'll start fucking with that shit,
figuring that out.
But, everything I'm gonna
talk about right now
will be ruined by us collectively,
and that's just the way it is,
and that's fine.
Snapchat emerges right?
Tonnes of 16 to 22 year olds there,
and if you want to sell something to them,
well that would be a good place to go,
because all of their attention is there.
And that friction,
cops and robbers,
cat and mouse,
will go on forever.
When there's a cave,
let's keep using that analogy,
when there's a cave with
a whole bunch of mice
if I'm the first cat to say you know what,
they're not hanging
out over there anymore,
all the mice are over here,
and I come there
there's a lot of mice to eat.
And so my game was quickly
to move into new places,
Facebook, the Internet itself
with my '96 eCommerce site,
and on and on,
Occulus Rift is coming.
Virtual reality.
Can you move first?
Find it, get the most value out of it,
then all the other cats come
they eat up all the other mice,
and now the cats, the marketers,
have ruined that location.
And that goes on over and over,
over and over,
and over again.
So if you people,
the fans, the peeps, the real life people,
if we all migrate our attention,
anywhere else it's just a matter of time,
until the cats come.
(Electronic music)